at a funeral in northern Albania a
community mourns the death of della of
indy yesterday a man shot deala but ween
the eyes as her daughter's looked on in
horror the killer a rejected suitor had
been stalking her for weeks while her
husband was overseas it's an outrageous
crime but many would find the
community's idea of justice equally
shocking the police and courts here once
powerful forces of order have become
weak now even though the state forbids
revenge killing
killers are seldom prosecuted many
Albanians are trying to end this cycle
of violence gin makes she is a
professional mediator with a committee
for blood reconciliation since the
committee was created in 1991 it has
reconciled hundreds of Albanian families
but it's just a start there are 2,000
families that shut themselves up in
their house 800 children that do not go
to school
it is something terrible for our country
hoping to end the violence for one
Albanian family embroiled in a blood
feud today mediator Jen makes she meets
with named Salemi
for ten grueling years name has lived
secluded from society in a compound with
barricaded walls
he told Jen the story of how his ordeal
began and that it was self-defense
I remember as though it was ten days ago
it was not meant to happen for outsiders
living under this form of tribal justice
may seem incomprehensible tradition
permits that name or his family may be
killed if they leave their property
trapped in his home name is unable to
work not even his children are safe from
revenge so they can't go to school and
must play at home instead
although there's a nearby market it's
too dangerous to shop their names family
struggles to survive off greens from
their garden and animal feed in this
case the victim's parents want to
forgive name I think of this is coming
from my soul I want to follow God's Way
on this one
God says to judge right but they are
unable to endless cycle of killing
because their sons insist on revenge the
two main reasons they will not forgive
they are filled with the pain they feel
for their brother and the second young
guys they judge inner - and they don't
think of the future everyone genly's
having earned only a promise that the
father will again ask his sons for peace
but in blood feuds the concept of
killing for honor is reinforced by
family and community it has been six
days since Delica vendee was killed her
family must now decide whether to follow
an old tribal code or a new system of
justice whatever the cuve Indies decide
as long as the state legal system is
weak and cultural values strong blood
feuds in Albania are likely to continue